we got generic Joe here
I got a t-shirt
I'm in Tech I don't want to get fans oh
okay so this isn't a non-call okay all
right so we're doing San Diego what's up
oh yeah yeah
um I'm pretty successful I'm like 33
um I work for big Tech uh you know I got
a sweet Loft I got all this stuff and uh
I'm just not having success dude in
dating I can't get them to go like three
four dates and I I just hate generic
stuff dude like
I'm not in the movies I'm not into like
pop culture I'm not into that type of
stuff
um full big tech nerd bro you know are
you at are you one of the fan companies
like getting paid 700 000 a year to
write code and do cool it's out
there man it's up there it's not quite
that level but it's not there and okay
but I mean like you've got that kind of
earning potential right yeah yeah and
I'm just not finding it dude uh okay so
so what do you think the problem is with
the girls
because I mean money's not a problem for
you right
yeah yeah that's not an issue
um dude I'm I'm on dude I got a
forerunner we're going Outdoors we're
going
I saw I don't think it's me I don't
think it's me um a lot of them are
saying emotional connection
or emotional life you know what that
means emotional connection there's no
emotional connection you know
uh
they're probably saying what does a chat
think it means you know since we're on
the topic so in the chat what do you
think there's no emotional connection
means but generic Johnson what do you
think it means not into you
she doesn't take your Vibe enough yeah
it's her way to say no
so so why do you think that these gals
are not into you like what What's
missing
that's what I don't know man I'm
pursuing Excellence I'm trying to work
out um
I'm trying to do the basketball
okay so what do you do for fun like you
like to drive your Forerunner what do
you do you take them off-roading yeah
sorry what do you do for dates man
that's what I do that's what I do well
first date it's like coffee or something
but then okay we'll go out to the
Forerunner a rental bike we'll go
mountain biking and stuff and it just
it it doesn't keep them bro it doesn't
keep them and that's where I'm like dude
I've been at it like three years out
here I don't know if it's like the West
coasts
Vibe we've got like just some Becky's
out here that don't like having fun
how many
um how many gals have you dated
like gone on more than one okay it was
yeah
it's a lot of money it's it's like 50
plus
what are you not getting exactly you're
not getting a third date you're not
getting right around like three or four
intimacy right around like day three or
four they're like
no just don't dig your Vibe don't okay
are you
are you are you closing them like you
going for the intimacy yeah yeah for
sure and are you closing them
uh no I get shut down all the time man
like what it's just kind of weird uh
if you got advice man I don't know okay
well let's see what the chat's saying
over here so I'm gonna so I'm gonna
start with that
um
we're seeing
what are you doing to seduce them
uh the San Diego shirt ain't it you're
too boring
um
captivating
stop wearing t-shirts with logos
confidence I'm not wearing these on the
dates you know don't worry I got
something else
uh no genuine burning desire he seems to
be beta would you say you're an alpha
male or a beta male
uh
I mean
I'm working on that Alpha man I'm
working on it trying to get to it okay
so I think on a scale of one to ten to
achieve it I'm always trying to get
there got it okay so with a scale of one
to ten with 10 being the absolute best
version of yourself you've reached the
Pinnacle of generic Joe and zero being
right at the very bottom where do you
where do you place yourself
probably like a six
ah have you read my book
no I have not forgot to jump on it okay
well this is my book it's called the
unplugged Alpha it's also the title of
the podcast you should definitely get it
there's a chapter in the book on how to
use online dating now
I specifically state in the book If
You're Gonna rate yourself like a seven
or under you're not going to get a lot
of good results dating do you do you
date girls from work or do you use
dating apps like what are you using
right now I mean I have a lot of success
online like
I don't sorry you just finished telling
me you don't have any success
meeting online I don't have success you
get the date in the ltrs like I want a
long-term relationship something that
okay is gonna work so we'll get to oh I
get tons of meetups right so okay
so all that means is that you've got
decent photography and that you're
probably a good looking guy like all I
can see is from here down and yeah I
mean also I don't know what you look
like in the face I mean you're not fat
obviously yeah um I would throw a little
more muscle on that frame if exactly if
that was me that's gonna obviously you
know give you a little bit more of an
advantage but at the end of the day like
if you're only rating yourself like a
six out of ten women usually only are
only interested in chasing the top you
know 20 of guys
so if you're like a six or seven out of
ten you're gonna have a hard time
getting attention to women because
they're chasing all the Chads and the
tyrones and the pookies right
I guess so yeah yeah I mean
so what can you do to get yourself from
a six to an eight
I'm asking you like that's a question so
what do you think you you know like you
got to do
what if money's not an issue for her
you're obviously in the top income
bracket for your age range right yeah
yeah I mean
I just got bulk up a bit I think
um what's your height
I'm 510.
510 and what's your weight
or 175.
so 510 175. so if you if you threw
another 10 15 pounds of muscle on your
frame you look a lot better so that'll
be helpful but that's not going to get
you tonight so what else are you missing
okay um
I'm not good at text game
um for example like I'll set up dates
um
you know the next week or whatever or
when I when I set up a date it's kind of
just like small thought set up a date
and a lot of them are saying like they
want this emotional
uh
play you know and I'm I'm terrible at
that do you think that's a thing like
emotional
um
generating that desire isn't just in
person yeah without playing it up
without you showing me some some like
screen caps of like
um threads back and forth with girls
that you're talking to it's it's it's
going to be tough you know for me to
assess
but at the end of the day I mean like
you haven't even started with the basics
like reading my book and my book covers
a lot of the fundamentals when it comes
to getting better results when dealing
with women
um get it dude like you know like read
the book and go through it there's an
entire chapter that deals with dating an
online game it's not complicated right
like a lot of guys will over complicate
you know dating and you have to do this
and you have to nag this and you have to
do that okay look you're already getting
like loads of dates like you've stated
that you got 50 dates the reason why
they're not interested in you is
probably not because
um you're not a good looking guy or that
you're not tall enough because otherwise
why would they be going out with you
because they've already assessed you is
that you're boring them in real life
that's just the that's just the reality
of it right like you have to be
captivated
is it my job to keep them entertained
like like I'm it is
it is your job to be entertaining
because there's a guy out there with a
boat that will invite her and all of her
girlfriends on the boat
right and entertain the out of them
or have a ski chalet up in the mountains
and invite them up there and entertain
the out of them right it is your
job to entertain women uh you can do
anything to a woman except for both
except for bore her right you know it's
a fact
so you definitely want to make sure that
you're more captivating like it's one of
the pillars of Attraction when it comes
to women and keeping women around it's
something that you know like the guys in
the Mano swamp don't talk about they
just focus on be good looking have good
game you know buy my course on pickup or
whatever it's like no dude like you have
to be captivating like that's probably
one of the most important things I've
seen a lot of Rich good-looking guys
that are boring as that have the
exact same problem that you have because
they're not captivating they don't know
how to engage them and keep them
interested and tease them and you know
push and pull them sort of back in in
their lives sort of thing you got to
play with chicks dude like you know the
that's a Cyndi Lauper song Girls Just
Want to Have Fun
yeah yeah I mean I feel like I can have
like if I need another tech bro dude
like we're going out we're talking about
like the sauna we're talking about ice
baths we're talking about all this we're
talking about like being in nature
lowering cortisol levels we're like
we're going like crazy Pam on like some
of this biohacking stuff that you've
been talking about so like like
I don't think yeah but you're not yeah
but you're not gay so you're not going
to be banging these dudes like you're
looking for women right
yeah exactly it's like it's like
specifically said I'm looking for a
long-term relationship yeah yeah yeah
and what kind of experience you have
with girls have you had any kind of
long-term relationships in the past have
you ever ever had a girlfriend yeah I
had a three-year LTR
okay and then like prior to that like
how many women have you dated in total
that have gotten to like you know beyond
one or two dates
like Beyond like
LTR is beyond that probably like
four or five
so you've had one LTR and you've had
four or five that went beyond one or two
dates
no four or five ltrs I I
meeting them is not the issue that like
it's keeping them it's keeping them yeah
yeah so that so that means you're a good
looking guy you photograph well you know
dating apps work you know great for you
fine awesome but you're not able to keep
them around so retention is a problem
yes yeah
okay captivation is what you have to
work on I mean there's some game element
to that too you can go read um you know
who's you know who's got some good
material that I still endorse is Troy
Francis
um he's got these like manuals you can
find them on Twitter you know if you
search for uh
um Renegade Playboy somebody in the chat
if you can put his uh you know put his
handle or his website please
um you know you can grab that and you
can read through that
um another option is I do one-on-one
consults you're getting paid well my
rate's High I mean if you want to book
me for an hour I'm happy to talk to you
privately you know we'll get to the
bottom of exactly what the problems are
take a look at some text threads and
stuff like that and I'll and I'll coach
you you know one-on-one in that sense
there's different ways to do it but the
attraction component isn't the problem
for you the problem is you're getting
frustrated because you're because you're
doing the Attraction part but they don't
want to see you be on a couple of dates
because they don't feel anything
yeah yeah the feeling part is just
you're just not captivating them right
like you're not you're not giving them
something like you got to be sticky you
know what I'm saying
yeah like a guy like you if you're good
looking and you make good money your
your problem you know should be like
I got three chicks that want to see me
this Saturday and I'm too busy and these
two are real hot and I don't really know
what you want to pick like that should
be your problem
I mean I can make that your problem if
you want I mean if you want to book me
foreign
dating seems to go in season so like
after the holidays and stuff like
everyone wants to date right so I'll get
like a bunch of dates on the weekend so
I'll be like oh perfect I got like four
or five people that I'm gonna go on
dates with for the next month or
whatever and then none of them end up
working out it's like um
okay well I've offered you you know I've
offered you some solutions I mean I
can't coach you through right to the
solution because I try to keep these to
like five ten minutes and do something
you need more than five or ten minutes
of my time so if you want you know if
you got the means to my link is pinned
in the top of all videos if you want to
book a call alternatively get my book
and read it because it's like 10 bucks
it's a five hour read tops
and start with that and if you want to
you know continue reading I'd get Troy
francis's books on pickup and gaming
women and stuff like that so that you
know how to Captivate them and you know
make yourself a lot more sticky so you
got a couple options there my friend
cool I wish you the best all right good
luck man
that's tough
a lot of guys out there you know it's
like you know they have
you know they have something going on or
they think that they're interesting like
I've you know I'll take them 4Runner
ring or I'll take a mountain bike you
know what I would do look if you like
off-roading if you like you know Jeeping
or forerunnering or uh what do they call
it over Landing or whatever it happens
to be I'd be like look Becky
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
go out this weekend I'm gonna load up a
forerunner you're gonna make a picnic
for us all right this is what I like to
eat gonna pick up this you know to drink
we're gonna go for a rip through the
desert you're gonna love this it's a
great Vista that I'm going to take you
you sell her the story right
she packs up the picnic Matt's down
great Drive banter banter laugh laugh in
the car joke joke joke poke make out
next thing you know you know could be
smashing pulling cactus thorns out of
your butt right you see what I'm saying
right like you like you know you can use
whatever it is you happen to do you know
to to your advantage when it comes to
women you just have to Captivate them
and like guide them women like one of
the great mistakes a lot of people in
like the fan companies like the tech
companies you know they have is they're
like men and women are equal and you
know I just have to be polite and you
know nice and all that sort of stuff and
that's not what women want they want to
be led in a relationship they want a guy
to be a guy they you know they they
want an you know there's an old
saying in England uh you know you got to
be Keen sorry to to keep them Keen you
got to be a bit mean right and I'm not
saying you have to be an but
there's probably an inner where
they knew that you have to kind of tune
in a little bit more and just tell them
this is what we're gonna do you're gonna
pack this this in the picnic we're gonna
hop in the Forerunner we're going to go
over Landing got this great Vista don't
take it very many people to it but I
found it the other day it's a brand new
one I want to show it to you sell her
this story right
anyway that's how I would do it if I was
in his shoes I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out